Joston Ramon Theney, Screenwriter, Author,
Director, Producer: I told my mom I’m absolutely
over the moon that nobody took
me seriously in the beginning.
Film Courage: How many
screenplays have you written?
Joston: I have lost count, I have lost count.
More than 50, more than 50, I can say that.
Film Courage: Feature screenplays
or a mixture of shorts and features?
Joston: No those will be all features,
mixture of features, mixture of pilots.
Film Courage: When did you write
your first feature screenplay?
Joston: Maybe about 18-19 and it was it was
called Audacious, that was the name of it
and nobody understood like “What is this?”
and I had to explain what “audacious” meant
but it was a vampire script.
Film Courage: Okay and you
were in Georgia at the time?
Joston: I was in Georgia yeah okay and I
think at that time I hadn't learned the
importance of titles. Titles have to
be strong and understandable and have
sometimes a couple of different meanings.
They can't just be self-indulgent
and everything I wrote had
some weird thing that I learned
but that was by far the weirdest title I
think I came up with which was Audacious.
Film Courage: What does it actually mean?
Joston: To live vicariously through
someone or something like a parasite.
Film Courage: Oh okay, interesting. Codependency?
Joston: Yeah and that's really what it was about,
this vampire needing this guy to
come to fruition to come to be.
Film Courage: What was your writing
process like on that first screenplay?
Joston: Making sure that the names were indented
properly and making sure spacing was appropriate
and the proper font was being used I was it was
so much still a learning process of just what went
into writing us a screenplay from a formatting
standpoint not a story structure standpoint
so at that point I hadn't even gotten into really
into the craft it was still very much just how do
I make this look professional so how long did it
take you to finish that screenplay oh five days
oh wow okay five days in the beginning I wrote
screenplays in a week or less in a week because
I didn't know what I didn't know like once you
understand what the craft really is and how
you how you get how you move an audience the
way you need to move them how do you get out
information without it being very convoluted or
heavy-handed how do you how do you get information
across both in text and subtext like once you
start getting into that and story structure it's
it complicates things and there's no way that
you're writing a script in a week and if you do
and it reads very well I'm impressed I'm impressed
because there's a lot of work that goes into it
just in terms of just outlining takes me about a
week or more just outlining it just to understand
what's going on in a very like one page kind of
way it takes a while so back then I didn't know
that so you when you don't know what you don't
know you just you plow right through it like I'm
done you drop it on the desk and for some reason I
think I think it's all because the industry was so
new to Georgia in the in the late 90s early
2000s like late 90s really and that's where I
really started to get a lot of
work and I'm turning in and stuff
that agent I don't I knew that he'd certainly
represented other writers and but I don't I
don't think he ever represented anybody who
was successful because there's no way you
could if you were receiving those kind
of screenplays and just being like whoa
whoa that's awesome there was no structure I
look back sometimes on some of the things i've
written like what was I thinking and it's just
because you you didn't know you don't know what
you don't know and so you're you're constantly
learning every time and especially when you seek
knowledge and you you don't have that vanity
to believe that you're the best at something
I never believe that I'm the best at anything
other than being me that that's really it and
I'm even sometimes I'm struggling with that right
so so I'm constantly looking at ways to improve
and as I began to understand story structure and
stuff like that my stories got better but it took
a while for me to get to the place where I am now
where I feel I feel as though I'm creating very
complete stories where you don't feel at the
end like what no I'm just missing something I
just can't figure out what it is I feel like my
stories are very complete now I feel they tell
a complete story and all the arcs are completed
and they're completed skillfully I'm always just
looking to figure out how to write a better
script the next time how do I how do I write
a better script the next time and then I start
okay I did this last time what do I improve but
what didn't I know that I know now and and that's
how you continue to grow but back then script in a
week was nothing do you think it would have helped
if you had this delusion where you thought your
thing was the greatest or your writing was the
greatest some people they're able to convince
everybody to that somehow I don't know I know
people like that I know people like that and
and don't get me wrong I don't mean I know people
like that who don't work I know people like that
who are working and some of the conversations
i've heard have been hilarious because this person
has I think in the arts because it is it is so
much it is so personal even if it's supposed
to be business it's really personal you create
something it came from you you birthed it right
and then you hear somebody look at two pages
and go that's garbage what else you got
you you either have to be able to
accept it and say that's not for them or
you become calloused and you become you develop a
sense of an inflated ego and I think that if you
if you develop the inflated ego which I think is
the go-to you you start stunting your growth as
a matter of fact i'd venture to say you start
regressing because when the going gets tough
you're going to fall back on the things and
you've never bothered to learn anything new
you're just going to fall back on the things
that you think have worked and I see that a lot
in the industry I don't think that's helpful
at all I think I think it's to your detriment
and when I say detriment I don't mean detriment
in terms of of your your marketability I i mean
in terms of your true ability to grow and become
your best you I think it's I think it's it's
detrimental with autis did you ever try to sell
it yes sadly the the agent did try to sell it and
he tried very hard and I don't blame anybody from
not for not buying it as a matter of fact I have
told this to everyone including my mom who thinks
I'm the absolute best I told my mom I'm absolutely
over the moon that nobody took me seriously in the
beginning because if they had and I had made any
of the number of screenplays that I had written
in the in the past in my in the very beginning
they would have laughed me out of here
and I would have never gotten another job
I think I would have never reached a point
where I felt as though I could take my career
into my own hands I never would have gotten there
because I think at that age if that happens to you
you're done I think you're done if somebody
if somebody cuts your legs off at 20
I think your legs are just gone I think you don't
have the stomach for it I see too many people that
come to la and they think they're going to be and
then they get their legs cut out from under them
and they go back to where they came from and they
are no longer interested in the business at all
so I'm very fortunate that nobody took me serious
except that one agent very serious I mean I think
everything happened exactly how it was supposed
to I on the one assignment that I was sent out on
and taken seriously and it was through a
sample not from me writing anything for
that specific pilot it was just from a sample
of my writing in general and that's how I was on
young Americans but if it had can you imagine if
I if they had wanted a submission like so a tv
show i'd written and I submitted something
it was like yeah here take a look at this
get out of here that's what would have happened
it was too green I didn't know enough so.